Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app find myself a popular hero. I was received as if I had won a great victory.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告广播并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，也可以在应用内订阅。我发现自己成了受欢迎的英雄。人们热烈欢迎我，仿佛我刚赢得了一场伟大的胜利。
The harbour was decorated with flags. Bands and crowds thronged the quays. The Admiral, the General, the Mayor pressed on board to grasp my hand. I was nearly torn to pieces by enthusiasm and kindness. Whirled along on the shoulders of the crowd, I was carried to the steps of the Town Hall, where nothing would content them but a speech, which, after a becoming reluctance, I was induced to deliver.
海港挂满了旗帜。乐队和人群挤满了码头。海军准将、将军、市长纷纷挤上船来跟我握手。我差点被大家的热情和善意给“撕碎”了。在人群的簇拥下，我被抬到了市政厅的台阶前，他们非要听我演讲不可，在一阵适时的推辞之后，我勉强发表了讲话。
So that, Dominic, the third of three brilliant impressions of Winston Churchill. I think your impressions have now reached a kind of decadent phase, Tom. They're increasingly incomprehensible. Well, if you could make that out, what Churchill was saying was that he's arrived in Durban
所以说，多米尼克，这是对温斯顿·丘吉尔的三次精彩模仿中的第三次。汤姆，我觉得你的模仿现在已经进入了一种颓废的阶段。它们越来越让人听不懂了。好吧，如果你能听懂的话，丘吉尔当时的意思是说他抵达了德班。
and he's the hero of the hour. And so basically, Dominic, everything we've been talking about, his great ambitions, his desire to cut a dash as an international hero has come true. And this is against into the details of why, what it is that Churchill does, the dramatic adventure he has that becomes a topic of obsessive international interest over the course of this episode. But I guess, first of all, we should do two things, shouldn't we? First of all, we should look at where Churchill is situated in terms of his career once he's
而且他是当之无愧的英雄。所以基本上，多米尼克，我们刚才谈到的一切——他伟大的雄心壮志，他渴望在国际舞台上出风头并成为国际英雄的愿望——都实现了。接下来我们要深入探讨丘吉尔究竟做了什么，他经历了怎样的戏剧性冒险，以至于在本集节目中成为了国际社会疯狂关注的话题。但我想，首先我们应该做两件事，对吧？首先，我们要看看丘吉尔从苏丹回来后，他的职业生涯处于什么位置。然后，我们要看看促使英国在南非向布尔人宣战的背景框架。这两件事都相当复杂。所以丘吉尔，对于听过前两集节目的听客们来说，他出生于1874年，有着贵族和美国血统。我们谈到了他那种悲惨的家庭出身，伦道夫和珍妮——他的父亲和母亲对他的糟糕养育。他上过哈罗公学，去过桑赫斯特。
come back from the Sudan. And then we should look at the framework that leads Britain to go to war in South Africa against the wars. Two quite complicated things. So Churchill, for those of you who listened to the first two episodes, born in 1874, aristocratic stroke American stock. We talked about his sort of miserable parentage, the miserable parenting of Randolph and Jenny, his father and mother. He's gone to Harrow. He's gone to Sandhurst.
他在古巴和印度都有过这些冒险经历。然后，当然还有在苏丹的经历，这成为了他未来更宏大故事的前奏——那就是他踏入政治舞台，以此来为他的托利党民主派父亲伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵正名。当他从苏丹回来时，他已经写了一本关于他在西北边境冒险经历的书。他又写了一本相当成功的书，叫做《河战》（The River War），讲述了他在基奈其军队一路开赴喀土穆期间的冒险经历。借助这种名气，他在奥尔德姆参加了他的第一场竞选。奥尔德姆的保守党人找到了他。所以，奥尔德姆对那些听众，尤其是非英国听众来说，是兰开夏郡的一个选区，向议会派遣了两名议员。这是一个类似棉纺织镇的地方。
He's had these adventures in Cuba and in India. And then, of course, in the Sudan with the preface to a greater story, which would be his entrance into the political arena to sort of vindicate the memory of his Tory Democrat father, Lord Randolph. And when he comes back from the Sudan, he's already written a book about his adventures in the Northwest Frontier. He writes another book called The River War, which is quite a success about sort of his adventures with Kitchener's army going all the way to Khartoum. And using that sort of fame, he fights his first election in Oldham. He's approached by the Conservatives in Oldham. So Oldham, for those people, particularly non-British listeners, it was a constituency in Lancashire that sent two MPs to Parliament. It's a kind of cotton town,
这是一个非常工阶级的城镇。所以丘吉尔发现那里没有酒店时很不高兴。所以这并不是一个显而易见的地方。保守党的地盘。不，但在那些日子里，我的意思是，人们经常代表那些与他们毫无关系的选区，他们甚至不会像现在这样假装他们内心深处热爱这个选区。但一个全都是纺织厂工人的城镇并不显眼。
very working class town. So Churchill was displeased to find that there was no hotel. So it's sort of not really an obvious place. Conservative territory. No, but in those days, I mean, people would often represent constituencies with which they had nothing, but they wouldn't even make the pretense as they do now that they deep down love the constituency. But a town full of mill workers isn't obvious.
我的意思是，这与马尔巴罗公爵的孙子显然格格不入。不，不，你完全说得对。事实上，当他在1899年7月参加这场竞选时，发生了一件有趣的事。所以这是一场补选。正如我所说，这里有两个席位。因此有两位激进自由党人，亚瑟·埃米特和沃尔特·龙西曼，后者是大历史学家史蒂芬·龙西曼爵士的父亲。
I mean, it's not an obvious congruence with the grandson of the Duke of Marlborough. No, no, you're absolutely right. And in fact, a funny thing happens when he fights this election in July 1899. So it's a by-election. So as I said, there are two seats. So there are two radical liberals, Arthur Emmett and Walter Runciman, the father of the great historian Sir Stephen Runciman.
你是十字军东征的历史学家，汤姆。你一定读过史蒂芬·龙西曼的书。但保守党推举了丘吉尔，还推举了一个叫莫兹利先生的人。莫兹利先生是操作纺工协会的秘书，所以他绝对是一个死硬的工人阶级保守党人。他是一个伟大的，他称自己为“托利党社会主义的捍卫者”。他说双方——丘吉尔在《我的早年生活》（My Early Life）中写道，他说莫兹利先生说。丘吉尔在《我的早年生活》中写道，莫兹利先生说，双方都很虚伪，但自由党人更甚。他很骄傲能与古老英国贵族的后裔同台，为了那些如此了解他的劳动人民的事业而发声。他们实际上是在以下标语下开展竞选的：
You're the Crusades historian, Tom. You must have read Stephen Runciman. But the Tories put up Churchill and they put up a man called mr maudsley mr maudsley is the secretary of the operative spinners association so he's an absolutely sort of died in the world working class tory he's a great sort of he calls himself the champion of tory socialism he says both parties churchill writes in my early life he says mr mauds. He says both parties, Churchill writes in My Early Life, he says, Mr. Morsley said that both parties were hypocritical, but the liberals were worse. He was proud to stand up on the platform with a scion of the ancient British aristocracy in the cause of the working people who knew him so well. And they actually sort of campaign under
“贵族与社会主义者”。这太棒了。对保守党来说，这简直是守住“红墙”的好招。完全正确，这非常具有“红墙”政治的特色，对吧？而且……呃，这让你了解到维多利亚时代晚期和爱德华时代的政治是怎样的，在很多方面它与我们现在所认为的选民结构有多么不同。不管怎样……呃，他们输了。他们并没有输很多，丘吉尔只输了，我的意思是，仅仅输了大约1200票左右……每个人都责怪他，但他并没有……他并没有失势，他没有，你知道的，他没有被羞辱，很明显，他完全有条件再试一次。汤姆，我在他的传记中读到过……安德鲁·罗伯茨在传记中提到这一刻时说，丘吉尔总是很好运。
the label, the scion and the socialist. That's great. There's something for the Tories to keep the red wall well exactly it is very kind of red wall politics isn't it and um uh gives you a sense of how ed war sort of lay victorian edwardian politics how different it was in many ways from you know what we assume the the constellation will be anyway um they lost they didn't lose by very much churchill lost by i mean only a what 1200 votes or something um everybody blamed him but he wasn't uh he wasn't disgraced he wasn't you know he wasn't humiliated it was clear that he would he was well placed to have another go i told him um in his biography and biography, Andrew Roberts says of this moment, Churchill always had good luck.
你知道的，伟大的政治家往往受到命运的青睐。如果丘吉尔在奥尔德姆赢了，他本可以赢的，那么在布尔战争爆发时，他就会在下议院里了。如果发生了那种情况，他就不会赢得如此非凡的名声——正如他在南非战争于年底爆发时所做的那样。我们应该谈谈南非战争，也就是布尔战争。这实际上是第二次布尔战争，对吧？但这场战争的根源可以追溯到相当久以前，因为开普敦最初主要是由来自尼德兰（即荷兰共和国）的人定居的，但也不完全是。他们自称为布尔人，也就是农民。
You know, great politicians are often sort of favoured by fortune. Had Churchill won in Oldham, as he could have done, he would have been in the House of Commons at the time of the outbreak of the Boer War. And had that happened, he would not have been able to make this extraordinary name for himself, which he does when the war in South Africa does break out at the end of the year. We should talk about the war in South Africa, the Burr War. It's actually the second Burr War, isn't it? But the roots of the war go back quite a long way because the Cape has been settled by mostly people from the Netherlands, the Dutch Republic, but not exclusively. And they take on the name of Boers, farmers.
然后英国人来了。他们在开普敦建立了一个殖民地，并且开始像他们所认为的那样，对布尔人进行“保姆式”的管理，因为英国人并不赞成布尔人的做法。让我们称之为一种对种族关系“不够进步”（unwoke）的处理方式吧。“不够进步”？这倒是一种说法。对。布尔人，让我们称之为对种族关系不够进步的处理方式吧。“不够进步”，这倒是一种说法。对。所以基本上，布尔人……好吧，我的意思是，这些人日后将会想出种族隔离政策。
Then the British arrive. They establish a colony at Cape Town, and they start nannying the Boers as they see it, because the British are not in favour of the Boers. Let's call it an unwoke approach to race relations. Unwoke? That's one way of putting it. Yeah. the Boers, let's call it unwoke approach to race relations. Unwoke, that's one way of putting it. Yeah. So essentially the Boers are, well, I mean, these are the people who in due course will come up with the policy of apartheid.
他们厌倦了他们眼中的英国人的指手画脚。于是他们爬上了大篷车，也就是自称为“布尔大迁徙者”的人，他们向内陆进发，向内陆进发。他们建立了三个共和国，对不对？是什么来着？纳塔尔、自由邦和德兰士瓦。纳塔尔是英国的。嗯，不对，因为在随后的发展中，布尔人深入内陆。英国人很高兴看到他们离开。
And they're fed up with what they see as British finger wagging. And so they pile into their wagons, the Boer trekkers, they call themselves, and they head off inland and they head off inland. And they establish three republics, don't they? What is it? Natal, Free State, and the Transvaal. Natal is British. Well, no, because in due course, the birds go inland. The British are content to see them go.
但在接下来的几十年里，出于各种战略原因，首先是这样。这就是为什么他们接管纳塔尔，因为那在海岸线上，所以他们想要东海岸。这对控制航运路线很重要。但在随后的发展中，德兰士瓦发生了一件事：1867年，一个人发现了所谓的“尤里卡钻石”。这是在德兰士瓦发现的第一颗巨大钻石。四年后，在一对名叫约翰尼斯·尼古劳斯（Johannes Nikolaus）和迪德里克·阿尔诺尔杜斯·德比尔（Diederik Arnoldus de Beer）的兄弟的农场上，又发现了更多的钻石。于是德比尔兄弟成立了一家公司。这当然就成为了世界上最著名的钻石公司。
But then over the course of the decades that follow, for various strategic reasons to begin with. So that's why they take over Natal because that's on the coast and so they want to the eastern coast. So that's important for controlling the shipping lanes. But then in due course, what happens in the Transvaal is that in 1867, a guy finds what is called the Eureka Diamond. So it's the first huge diamond to be found in the Transvaal. And then four years later, more diamonds are found on the farm of a pair of brothers who are called Johannes Nikolaus and Diederik Arnoldus de Beer. And so the de Beers form a company. And this becomes, of course, the most famous diamond company in the world.
你会看到各种各样的探险者，主要是英国人，蜂拥进入德兰士瓦。当发现黄金时，这种情况就更是如此了。德兰士瓦的领袖保罗·克鲁格（Paul Kruger）说，这是一场灾难，这些黄金将导致这个国家血流成河。这些话非常非常准确，因为基本上英国人，你知道的，他们想要它。他们想要钻石，也想要黄金。这是一个相当复杂的故事，一个引人入胜的故事。所以到了19世纪末，布尔人已经与英国人打过一仗，即第一次布尔战争，在那场战争中他们基本上进行了抗争并确立了他们的独立。而且他们赢了。
And you get all kinds of prospectors, mostly British, piling into the Transvaal. And that becomes even more so when gold is also discovered. And Paul Kruger, who is the leader of the Transvaal, says that this is a disaster, that this gold will cause the country to be soaked in blood. And these are very, very accurate words because basically the British are, you know, they want it. They want the diamonds and they want the gold. It's quite a complicated story, a fascinating story. So you have by the end of the 19th century, there had been, the Boers had fought a war against the British, the First Boer War, where they basically fought and they asserted their independence. And they won.
所以我认为，自美国独立战争以来，英国还从未在经历如此惨败之后谈判达成过一项条约。是的，马朱巴山之战。因此到了19世纪末，布尔人拥有两个布尔共和国——德兰士瓦和奥兰治自由邦。而东海岸则有两个实际上属于英国的殖民地——开普省和纳塔尔。发生了什么呢？部分原因是贪婪。部分原因是争夺资源。
So this is, I think, not since the American War of Independence had Britain negotiated a treaty in the wake of such a defeat. Yeah, Majuba Hill. So the Boers had, by the end of the 19th century, the two Boer republics, the Transvaal and the Orange Free State. And there are two British, effectively British sort of colonies, the Cape Colony and Natal on the East Coast. And what has happened? So part of it is greed. Part of it is the fight for resources.
正如你所说，这里有钻石，随着在约翰内斯堡周围的兰德地区发现黄金，还爆发了巨大的淘金热。这个巨大的矿坑形成了一个定居点，这就是约翰内斯堡。所谓的“外地人”（Uitlanders）蜂拥而至。他们没有选举权，因为布尔人不希望失去对政治权力的垄断。所以这就成了英国人的伟大借口之一。
So as you said, there's been the diamonds, and there's the huge gold rush with the discovery of gold on the Rand around Johannesburg. And this huge pit settles town and this becomes Johannesburg. What are called the outlanders have kind of piled in. They're not given the vote because the Boers don't want to lose their monopoly of political power. So that becomes one of the great British pretexts,
所有这些说英语的人，所有这些英国臣民，都蜂拥来到德兰士瓦，但他们不被允许投票，他们被剥夺了政治权利，而英国人想要……他们说他们要为这些人挺身而出。显然，英国人也想要黄金和钻石。他们还想消灭布尔共和国，你知道的，为了抹去第一次布尔战争战败的耻辱。他们还对塞西尔·罗兹（Cecil Rhodes）修建从开罗到开普敦的铁路的宏伟计划非常感兴趣。换句话说，他们想要让地图的整片区域都染上英国殖民地的粉红色。他们想要
that all these English speakers all these british subjects have piled into the transvaal in particular but they're not allowed to vote they are deprived of political rights and the british want to sort of they say they want to stand up for them obviously the british also want the gold and the diamonds they also want to eliminate the boer republics you know to sort of wipe away the stain of defeat in the first boer war they're also very interested in cecil rhodes's great project of the railway that will go from cairo to the cape so in other words they want a whole the map splashed within british imperial pink they want
一条从地中海一直延伸到南非最南端开普殖民地的铁路。而这两个布尔共和国挡在了这条路的中间。他们决心要……紧张局势不断升级、升级、升级。我们应该顺便提一下詹森 Jameson 突袭，对吧？因为其中一个参与者将在这段故事中出现。利安德·斯塔尔·詹森（Leander Starr Jameson）。多棒的名字啊。是的。
a line that goes all the way from the mediterranean all the way down to the Cape Colony at the very bottom of South Africa. And the two Boer republics sit in the way of that. And they are determined to. And tension mounts and mounts and mounts. We should just mention the Jameson Rage, shouldn't we? Because a participant in that will feature in this story. Leander Starr Jameson. What a great name. Yes.
那是1895年末、1896年初的事。它是从罗得西亚（也就是现在的津巴布韦）发起的。这是试图唤醒德兰士瓦境内的英国人的一次尝试。而这是一场惨败。这确实是一场失败。而且很明显，作为自由抢劫犯行事的詹森，是受人指使的，或者至少是在英国政坛大人物——也就是殖民地大臣约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain，伯明翰伟大的前市长）的默许下行事的。他可以说是那个时代当之无愧的政治泰坦，甚至可以说是比首相萨利伯瑞勋爵（Lord Salisbury）更有权势。他是对丘吉尔影响最大、丘吉尔最崇拜的兩三个政治人物之一。所以正如你所能看出的那样，当你阅读《我的早年生活》时，丘吉尔对纳维尔的父亲约瑟夫·张伯伦迷恋不已。他视其为那个时代伟大的政治巨擘。张伯伦是帝国主义的
So that's the latter days of 1895, the first days of 1896. It's launched from Rhodesia, so what's now Zimbabwe. And it's an attempt to kind of rouse the British in Transvaal. And it's a dismal failure. It is a failure. And it's pretty clear that Jameson, who was operating as kind of freebooter, had been put up to it, or at least was doing it with the complicity of the big man in British politics, who is the colonial secretary, Joseph Chamberlain, great former mayor of Birmingham. Very much the political titan of the age, arguably even more so than the prime minister, Lord Salisbury. And one of the two or three political characters who had, I think, most influence on Churchill, who Churchill most looked up to. So Churchill is, as you can tell, when you read My Early Life, he's obsessed with Joseph Chamberlain, father of Neville. And he sees him as the great sort of political colossus of the age. Chamberlain is the imperialist
杰出代表。他基本上想把布尔人从南非的地图上抹去，完成瓜分非洲的任务，给英国留下这片巨大的粉红色领土。因此，总的来说，英国对非洲的介入是土地掠夺和道德主义的结合。它关乎确立自己作为主要帝国力量的地位，但同时也真正热衷于废除奴隶贸易之类的事情。在确保德兰士瓦的英国臣民拥有投票权，以及确保德兰士瓦对非洲人的压迫得到某种程度的……
par excellence. He wants to wipe the burrs basically off the map of south of africa and complete the task of the sort of scramble for africa and giving britain this sort of huge swathe of of pink so generally britain's engagement in africa has been a fusion of of land grab and moralism it's been about establishing themselves as the kind of primary imperial power, but also authentically interested in getting rid of the slave trade, all that kind of thing. And there's kind of trace elements of that moralizing in the campaign to ensure that British subjects in Transvaal have the vote and also that the oppression of Africans in Transvaal is kind of,
不能完全说是彻底制止，但可以说是缓和的这场运动中，这种道德说教的痕迹其实相当微弱。我想，到了这个时候，这已经变得很苍白了。我认为本质上这是一场相当赤裸裸的土地掠夺，你不这么认为吗？我的意思是，你刚才对把我把它描述为不光彩的插曲发出了轻蔑的哼声。不，你说这是不良行为。我认为这就是不良行为。汤姆，我认为这就是冷酷无情的行为。
not exactly completely stopped, but moderated, let's say. But that is pretty thin gruel, I think, by this point. I think essentially this is a fairly naked land grab, wouldn't you say? I mean, you were harrumphing a little bit at my casting of this as an inglorious episode. No, you said it was bad behavior. I think it is bad behavior. I think it's just ruthless behavior, Tom.
我的意思是，这不像是他们在搜寻某个本土王国。我的意思是，这是一群不同的人，是一群对立的定居者。哦，不。所以这是欧洲人。对于英国国内的人来说，这正是乐趣的一部分，不是吗？他们对付过马赫迪和他的军队。那很容易。
I mean, it's not like they're sniffing out a kind of indigenous kingdom. I mean, this is a different set, a rival settler. Well, no. So it's Europeans. And that's what, for people back in Britain, is all part of the fun, isn't it? They've had their crack against the Mahdi and his army. And that was easy.
但现在这有点像进入了“欧冠联赛”或别的什么，这是一个晋级下一轮的机会……并且他们认为自己会一路赢下去。虽然我说这是冷酷无情行为，当然这绝对是冷酷无情行为，但我确实认为，总的来说，英国人用一种真正具有道德使命感的面纱，来掩饰他们在非洲的残酷无情，而这种使命感在布尔战争中并不存在，在布尔战争中是完全不存在的。这就是为什么这场战争在世界其他地方的舆论中极不受欢迎。我的意思是，这绝对是世界舆论的看法，尽管英国人试图把它当作巩固……
But now it's kind of like going you know champions league or something this is an opportunity through to the next round um and they assume that they're going to go all the way but i you say it's it's kind of ruthless behavior of course it's absolute ruthless behavior but i do think that in general the british had sugar-coated their ruthlessness in africa with an authentic moralizing sense of mission which isn't there in the burr war which is not there in the burr war and that is why it's a hugely unpopular war with the rest of world opinion i mean this is world opinion definitely although it's the british try to use it as a way of sort of cementing um imperial brotherhood so there are troops from you know australia and so on there are all kinds of recruitment things in Canada.
帝国兄弟情谊的一种方式——所以有来自澳大利亚等地的军队，加拿大也有各种各样的招兵买马活动。但在美国、在欧洲大陆，它被视为它本来面目，即恃强凌弱。人们认为这就是恃强凌弱。我觉得发生的这一切，带有一丝普京的影子。这太严厉了。英国人开始在德兰士瓦边境集结军队。实际上是布尔人宣战了。布尔人发出了最后通牒。是的，他们确实这么做了。
But in America, in continental Europe, it's seen, I think, as what it is, which is bullying. It is perceived as bullying. There's this kind of faint hint of Putin, I think, about what happens. That's very harsh. The British start to mass troops along the border of the Transvaal. It's the Boers who actually declare war. The Boers issue an ultimatum. Yes, they do.
他们确实发了。而英国人置之不理。于是战争爆发了。因此，布尔人的领袖保罗·克鲁格率先采取了行动。他认为他可以抢在英国人前面。气氛逐渐但稳定地变得紧张起来，充满了电荷，弥漫着暴风雨来临前的预感。天哪，他是那样说的吗，汤姆？差不多吧，是的。
They do. And the British ignore it. And so war breaks out. So Kruger, the leader of the Boers, Paul Kruger, he moves first. He thinks he can forestall the British. The atmosphere gradually but steadily became tense, charged with electricity, laden with the presage of storm. Golly, did he say it just like that, Tom? Pretty much, yeah.
天哪，好吧。所以丘吉尔当然很高兴。这是他进行伟大冒险的又一次机会。他在自传中写道：“我必须承认，在年轻的热情驱使下，我大为宽慰地得知，这场战争不会完全是一边倒的，也不会仅仅流于一场阅兵式或示威游行就草草收场。我觉得布尔人敢于向整个大英帝国挑战，是非常有体育精神的。”
Golly, well. So Churchill, of course, is delighted. This is another opportunity for him to go on one of his great adventures. He actually writes in his autobiography, I must confess that in the ardour of youth, I was much relieved to learn that the war would not be entirely one sided or Peter out in a mere parade or demonstration. I thought it very sporting of the birds to take on the whole British empire.
“而且我感到高兴的是，他们并非毫无防备，并且通过做准备而占理了。”所以他，你知道的，他对这件事采取了非常类似于“欧冠”的心态。这又是一场比赛。是的。他渴望参与其中。全力以赴。
And I felt glad that they were not defenseless and put themselves in the wrong by making preparations. So he's, you know, he very much takes the sort of champions league attitude to it. It's another match. Yeah. He's desperate to be in on it. Go for gold.
他又一次获得了一份利润丰厚的报纸合同，这次是为《晨邮报》（Morning Post）工作。这在当时是一名战地记者的记录。他们同意在四个月内支付他1000英镑。为了让大家有个概念——我们在第一集里实际上提到了这一点——柯南·道尔在那儿。鲁德亚德·吉卜林在那儿。埃德加·华莱士（Edgar Wallace）——他创作了催生《金刚》（King Kong）的原著故事——也在那儿。所以很多非常杰出的作家都去了，但丘吉尔是
He gets it yet again, another lucrative newspaper deal, this time with a morning post. It's a record at this point for a war correspondent. They agree to pay him £1,000 for four months. To put that in context, we mentioned this actually in the first episode, that Conan Doyle is out there. Rudyard Kipling is out there. Edgar Wallace, who writes the original story that gives rise to king kong is out there so a lot of very eminent writers are going out but churchill is the best
薪水最高的一个。我想原因不仅在于他是一位非常优秀的作家，还在于他以深入危险核心而闻名。是的。每个人都知道他会陷入麻烦。每个人都知道他会搞到独家新闻。是的。于是他出发了。宣战三日后他扬帆起航。他随身携带了六箱克拉雷特红葡萄酒、香槟和烈酒。
paid of the lot and i think the reason for that isn't just that he is um a very good writer but it's also his reputation for going to you know the, the heart of danger. Yeah. Everyone knows he'll get into trouble. Everyone knows that he'll get scoops. Yeah. So he goes off. He sets sail three days after war is declared. He takes with him six cases of claret, champagne, and spirits.
所以他绝对做好了充分准备。他晕船得很厉害，对不对？他是晕船的。船上有一位来自《卫报》（当时叫《曼彻斯特卫报》）的人。他写了一段非常优美的文字，我认为这是对年轻丘吉尔最好的描述之一。他将他描述为这样一个在甲板上走来走去的快乐家伙。他说：“我以前从未遇到过这种野心，毫无掩饰、坦率地以自我为中心，传达着他的兴奋并强求共鸣。并不是说他缺乏自我批判的能力。”
So he's absolutely well prepared. He's very seasick, isn't he? He is seasick. One of the people on the boat is from the Guardian, the Manchester Guardian. And he writes a lovely, I think it's one of the best descriptions of the young Churchill. So he describes him as this sort of jolly fellow kind of going around the deck. And he says, I had not before encountered this sort of ambition, unabashed, frankly, egotistical, communicating his excitement and extorting sympathy. It was not that he was without the faculty of self-criticism.
“他会嘲笑自己对荣耀的梦想，他有一种顽皮的幽默感。”我认为这非常贴切。是的，对不起。他很有雄心，他很自负。他意识到自己滑稽的一面，并且经常喜欢拿这一点来开玩笑。我认为这是让他显得可爱的原因之一。但他坐上了雷弗斯·布勒（Redvers Buller）的船，对吧？雷弗斯·布勒是一位名字很响亮的指挥官，是被任命领导英国军队的人。基本上，他们需要穿卡其服，尽管许多人对此感到非常沮丧。但人们有一种感觉：英军就像一头笨重的公牛，正等着被更加敏捷、机动的布尔农民智取。
He could laugh at his dreams of glory and he had an impish fun. I think that's very much. Yeah, I'm sorry. He's ambitious, he's bumptious. He's aware of his own comic side and he often likes to play up to that. I think it's one of the things that makes him endearing. But he's on the boat, isn't he, with Redvers Buller, who is the splendidly named commander, the man who's been appointed to lead the British forces. And essentially, he's need to wear khaki, although lots of people are very distressed about this. But there is a sense that the British army is a ponderous bull that is just waiting to be outsmarted by the far more agile and mobile Burr farmers.
事实也的确如此。因为尽管英国是世界上首屈一指的帝国强国，但英国并不是一个擅长陆军的国家。我的意思是，我们太依赖海军了。自从滑铁卢战役以来，除了克里米亚战争之外，当陆军作战时，往往是在对付那些在技术上远远落后且更加乌合之众的土著民族。所以他们实际上并不太擅长打陆战。而且布尔人的武器实际上更好，对吧？
And so it proves. Because even though Britain is the world's foremost imperial power, Britain is not a great army country. I mean, we relied so much on the Navy. And when the army had fought, with the exception of Crimea, since the Battle of Waterloo, the army has tended to fight technologically greatly inferior and more disorganized kind of indigenous peoples. So they're not really very good actually at fighting land battles. And the birds actually have better weaponry, don't they?
他们有更好的步枪。在英国人看来，基本上他们是在作弊。他们不以缓慢、笨重的红色方阵列队行进。他们躲在岩石后面，拿着他们的毛瑟枪，其射速和射程都比英国的李·恩菲尔德步枪更快、更远。而且他们在马术上也极其精湛，丘吉尔甚至声称他们是自蒙古人以来
They've got better rifles. Basically, it seems to the British they're cheating. They don't kind of march out in slow, ponderous red lines. They hide behind rocks with their mouses, which can shoot faster and at greater distance than the British Lee Enfields. And they're also very, very proficient on horseback and churchill actually claims that they're the most capable mounted warriors since the mongols
基本上自蒙古人以来最能干的骑兵。所以当雷弗斯·布勒带着丘吉尔抵达开普敦时，战争对英国人来说已经错得一塌糊涂了，因为是的，布尔人已经转入进攻。他们不只是固守在德兰士瓦，他们已经出击了。他们从德兰士瓦出发。他们从奥兰治自由邦出发。有一条铁路线将约翰内斯堡连接到德班，后者在德兰士瓦境内，也就是在英国控制的领土之内。布尔人能够……他们对英军造成了如此多的惨败，以至于他们有能力包围并围困它。这基本上就是丘吉尔抵达时的情景。对丘吉尔来说，这一切都是为了赶往莱迪史密斯。那么汤姆，我们是否应该在这里休息一下，然后重新开会，看看丘吉尔发生了什么？让我告诉你，
and essentially since the mongols say by the time that redvers bulla with churchill arrives in cape town it the war has already gone disastrously wrong for the british because yes the birds have gone on the offensive they haven't just kind of hunkered down in the transvaal they've've kind of moved out. And they march out from Transvaal. They march out from the Orange Free State. And there is a rail line that links Johannesburg to Durban, which is on the the Transvaal, so within British controlled territory. And the Boers are able, you know, they inflict so many defeats on the British arms that they're in a position to invest it and lay it under siege. And that is basically the situation when Churchill arrives. And it's all about getting to Ladysmith for Churchill. So should we take a break here, Tom, and reconvene to find out what happens to Churchill? And let me tell you,
起初情况并不妙，所以我们在休息后回来看看究竟发生了什么。再见，戏剧性。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的本质》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、
at first it's not good, so we'll come back after the break to see what it is. Bye-bye, drama. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告广播、加更节目并优先获得现场门票，请访问 the rest is entertainment.com，也就是 the rest is entertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们现在位于纳塔尔省的埃斯科特镇，也就是现在的南非。温斯顿·丘吉尔已经去了那里。他在火车站，与一小支英国部队在一起。他们知道在布尔人控制区之外的灌木丛中某处有敌人，但他们不知道敌人确切在哪里。
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are in the town of Estcourt in Natal, in what is now South Africa. And Winston Churchill has gone out there. He's at the railway station with a small British force who know that somewhere out there in the sort of the scrublands beyond the Burrs, but they don't know exactly where they are
汤姆，1899年11月15日星期三，埃斯科特守备部队的指挥官决定派出一列装甲列车进行巡逻，丘吉尔听说了这件事，非常渴望前往，对吧？好吧，因为他想去莱迪史密斯。所以埃斯科特就在离莱迪史密斯不远的铁路线下方，因此……这个点子就是：你用装甲列车沿着铁路线向上开，从丘吉尔的角度来看，这有望把他带到足够接近莱迪史密斯的地方，然后他就可以跳下火车，潜过布尔人的防线，进入莱迪史密斯，写独家报道，那将是一件大快人心的事。然而，当你面对的是非常机动、非常敏捷、极其擅长躲在岩石后面的部队时，派出一列非常缓慢笨重的火车，可能并不是最好的策略，因为基本上你是把自己变成了一个活靶子，等着敌人来伏击。而这正是发生的事情。是的，所以他们行驶了14英里……我的意思是，这是丘吉尔生命中的一个绝对转折点，因为这比其他任何事情都更能让他成名。说来有趣，如果你在一战前的任何时候，甚至可以说在一战后的几年里，问人们温斯顿·丘吉尔因为什么而出名？
and tom wednesday the 15th of november 1899 the commander of the garrison at escort decides that he's going to send an armored train out on patrol and uh churchill hears about this and he's very keen to go isn't he well because he wants to get to lady smith so escort is just down the line from uh from lady smith and so is just down the line from uh from lady smith and so the wheeze is that you you send an armored train up the up the railways and this hopefully would from churchill's point of view would take him close enough to lady smith that he could then hop off sneak through the burr lines and get into lady smith and write exclusives and it will be great hurrah however there is a problem when you're up against very mobile very agile
大家都会说起那列火车上的插曲以及接下来发生的事。于是他们向北行驶了14英里，开往一个叫切夫利（Cheveley）的地方。他们实际上在地平线上发现了看起来像布尔游击队的人。丘吉尔——我的意思是，他在自己的叙述中把这一点稍微弄得有些模糊。但其他人基本上说丘吉尔当时非常狂热。他说，哦，我们真的不用担心这个。这绝对没问题。因为他在那儿。
troops who are very very adept at hiding behind rocks sending in a very slow and ponderous train perhaps isn't the best policy because essentially you're making yourself an absolute sitting duck for an ambush and that is exactly what happens yes so they travel 14 i mean this is an absolute turning point in churchill's life because it's the moment more than anything else that makes them famous. So funnily enough, if you said to people at any point up to the first world war and arguably in the years after the first world war, what is Winston Churchill famous for?
他既是一名战地记者，但当然，他也有点像个好战分子，因为你知道他……他武装了自己，是的，他有……完全正确，他有历史……不管怎样，他们继续开着，突然间——在丘吉尔的自传《我的早年生活》中，有一段非常精彩、带有swashbuckling（披风刀剑片）风格的戏剧性叙述——突然间出现了耀眼的闪光，一团巨大的白色烟球腾空而起，在我头顶上方炸成一个圆锥形，榴弹碎片到处乱飞。列车前方传来一声巨烈的撞击声，各种爆炸和震动接踵而至。然后他们都被抛得人仰马翻，摔倒在车厢地板上。基本上发生的情况是，
It would be the episode with the train and then what happens next. So they steam for 14 miles North to towards a place called Cheveley. And they actually spot what looked like burr gorillas sort of on the horizon. And Churchill, I mean, he muddies this a bit actually in his own account. But other people basically say Churchill is very gung-ho. And he says, oh, we don't really need to worry about that. It'll be absolutely fine. Because he's there.
布尔人让火车出轨了。他们在铁轨上放了石头。他们给英国人设下了陷阱。他们让列车出轨了。现在，正当丘吉尔和他的战友们摇摇晃晃地站起来寻找掩护时，布尔人正把炮弹和子弹倾泻到那堆撞毁的列车残骸上。这是一个极其戏剧化、好莱坞式的场景。事实上，丘吉尔随后表现出了极大的勇气和骑士风度。所以他
He's both a war correspondent. But, of course, there's a slight element of him being a competent as well because you know he's he's armed yeah he's he's got exactly he's got the history uh anyway they run on then suddenly i mean there's an absolutely fantastic swashbuckling kind of dramatic account in my early life churchill's um autobiography there are suddenly these bright flashes of light, a huge white ball of smoke sprang into being and tore out in a cone above my head and shrapnel flying everywhere. There's a gigantic crash from the front of the train and all kinds of explosions and a shock. And then they're all sort of pitched head over heels onto the floor. And basically what has happened is
振作起幸存者。他们试图把一些货车搬离铁轨。指挥官幸存下来了，对不对？是一个叫霍尔丹（Haldane）的家伙，队长……是的。叫什么来着？埃尔默（Aylmer）？是埃尔默吗？我不记得了。埃尔默·霍尔丹，我想是的。诸如此类。是的。埃尔默，是吗？埃尔默？我不记得了。埃尔默·霍尔丹，我想是的。诸如此类。是的。所以他和他的部队在那里。但丘吉尔在这其中的勇气真的是惊人的，因为他冲上前去，指挥大家
the Boers have derailed the train. They put rocks on the line. They've laid a trap for the British. They've derailed the train. And now they are pumping shells and bullets into the kind of crashed hulk of the train while Churchill and his comrades are sort of staggering to their feet and trying to get cover. So it's an incredibly dramatic kind of Hollywood-ish scene. And actually, Churchill then behaves with tremendous sort of courage and gallantry. So he
试图把火车重新弄回铁轨上，对吧？把石头搬走，把火车弄回铁轨上，这样它就可以开走了。子弹在周围……呼啸。一直在呼啸。我的意思是，从古巴开始，这就是丘吉尔一贯的故事：他将自己置身于激烈的战斗中心，他完全
kind of rallies the survivors. They try to get some of the trucks off the line. The commander has survived, hasn't he? And he's a chap called Haldane, Captain... Yes. What's his name? Aylmer? Is he Aylmer? I can't remember. Aylmer Haldane, I think it is. Something like that. Yes. Aylmer, is he? Aylmer? I can't remember. Aylmer Haldane, I think it is. Something like that. Yes. So he's there with his troops. But Churchill's courage in this is really spectacular because he kind of rushes forward and he takes command of the effort
有一种在枪林弹雨中保持镇定的非凡天赋。所以假设他头脑清醒……后来人们说，他当时若无其事地走来走去，说“弟兄们，保持冷静”。有时他甚至大言不惭地说：“这对于写报纸来说会很有趣。”如果你是那些害怕被击中的英国士兵之一，听到这话一定气炸了。但他确实做了这一切。他找到了火车司机，而那个司机是个平民，被榴弹碎片击中了，
to try and get the train back on the tracks, doesn't he? Get the rocks off, get the train back on the track so it can then steam off. And the bullets are kind of firing. Pinging. Pinging all the time. I mean, it's very much like from Cuba onwards, this has been Churchill's story, that he puts himself in the thick of the action he's completely
脸上血流如注。丘吉尔说：“你觉得重新启动火车，顶着这一切开过去怎么样？”火车司机基本上回答说：“我才不干呢。这绝对是我最不想做的事。”丘吉尔对他说：“你难道不知道一个人在同一天被击中两次在统计学上是不可能的吗？所以如果你已经被击中过一次，你绝对就安全了。”
he has this extraordinary gift of not losing his composer under fire so suppose his head well people later on say that he was he was sort of walking around blithely saying keep cool men and sometimes he actually has the effrontery to say, this will be interesting for the paper, which must be absolutely enraging to hear if you're one of the British soldiers terrified of being hit. But he does all this. He gets the engine driver, and the engine driver, who is a civilian, he's been hit by shrapnel,
没有危险。如果你受了伤并且表现出勇敢，你绝对会得到一枚勋章。我会确保你得到勋章，而且你这辈子再也不会有这样的机会了。”令人惊奇的是，火车司机屈服于丘吉尔的恳求，基本上擦掉了血迹，爬回了驾驶室，服从命令试图重新启动火车。
so there's blood pouring from his face. And Churchill says, how do you fancy restarting the train and driving on through all this? And the train driver basically says, not bloody likely. You know, this is the last thing I want to do. And Churchill says to him, do you not know that it's statistically impossible for somebody to be hit twice on the same day? So if you've been hit once, you're absolutely fine.
说实话，多年后，当丘吉尔担任内政大臣时，他还特意找到了这位火车司机，确保他被授予了阿尔伯特勋章——这是授予平民的最高勇敢奖章。那已经是十多年后的事了。所以这是一个能让人对每个人都留下好印象的故事，我想。于是火车开走了，对吧？但丘吉尔被俘了，主要是因为他把枪落下了。所以他别无选择。嗯，许多人都被留下了，当火车逃跑时，他们不可能全部撤离，所以很多人被留下了，丘吉尔就是其中之一。呃，正如你所说，他有他的……他把枪落下了，所以他被一个骑兵逼入了绝境……
There's no danger. If you've been wounded and you behave a gallantry, you'll definitely get a medal. And I will make sure you get a medal and you'll never get this chance again in your life. And amazingly, the engine driver succumbs to Churchill's entreaties and basically wipes off the blood and climbs back into his cab and obeys his orders to try and restart the train.
在极不情愿的情况下，他最终像其他人一样挥舞起手帕。他们被布尔人俘虏了。但幸运的是，从某种层面上说，没带枪很不幸，因为否则他可以开枪杀出一条血路。
And actually, to his credit, Churchill, many years later, when he was Home Secretary, he tracked down the train driver and made sure that he was awarded the Albert Medal, the highest reward for gallantry for civilians. That was more than a decade later. So that's a story that reflects well
但从另一个方面来说，这又非常幸运，因为如果他在被俘时随身带着枪，他作为无辜记者的辩解就会让他陷入真正的危险之中，我认为。确实如此，因为那样他就会被当成间谍。是的。你看，正因如此，他可以声称自己是——正如你所说——一名战地记者。他一被俘，
on everybody, I think. So the train goes off, doesn't it? But Churchill gets captured, basically because he's left his gun behind. So he has no choice. Well, there's a lot of the men have been left they can't all go off when the engine escapes so a lot of them left behind churchill's one of them uh as you said he's he had his he's he's left his gun so he's cornered by a horseman um and very reluctantly he eventually waves his handkerchief like all the others do. And they're taken prisoner by the Boers. But it's lucky that he, I mean, at one level, it's very unlucky that he didn't have his gun because otherwise he could have shot his way out.
就对布尔人说：“我是战地记者。你们必须放我走。你知道的，根据战争法，你们不能把我当俘虏。”其中一个人据称对他说：呃，
But in the other way, it's very lucky because if he'd had his gun with him when he was captured, his claim to be an innocent journalist would have put him in real danger, I think. It would because he would then have been a spy. Yeah. See, because he's, as it is, he can claim to be, as you said, a war correspondent. He, as soon as they're captured,
我们可抓不到……的儿子，他们认出了他的名字。其中一个人对他说：“我们可不是每天都能抓到一个勋爵的儿子的。”嗯，不仅仅是随便哪个勋爵，因为伦道夫·丘吉尔过去对布尔人的态度出了名的粗鲁，对吧？所以这里面有着真正的积怨，因此他们很高兴能抓到伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵的儿子，绝对下定决心不放过他。于是他们……他们
he says to the Boers, I'm a war correspondent. You have to let me go. You know, under the laws of war, you're not allowed to take me a prisoner. And one of them supposedly says to him, uh,
把他和其他所有人塞进一辆火车，锁起来，不准下车，他们抵达了比勒陀利亚。在那里，有一所三年前建立的教师培训学院，叫做“斯图茨模范学校”（Stutz Model School），他们就被关在那里，被囚禁在那里。是的。丘吉尔说，当他们到达那里时，感觉就像是一个私立学校的新生。他居然在身陷囹圄时，还试图让人量身定制一套西装，并请人进来给他剪裁。是的，一套花呢西装。他还请当地理发师来给他理发。这看起来介于监狱、寄宿学校和酒店之间，我觉得。
we don't catch the son of, they know they recognize his name. And one of them says to him, we don't catch the son of a Lord every day. Well, not just any Lord because Randolph Churchill had been notoriously rude about the burrs had he yeah so there's a real a real grudge there so they're they're delighted to have lord randolph churchill son in their hands absolute determined not to lose him and so they they um they they put him
这很符合布尔人的风格，因为……他们受到了很好的优待。丘吉尔对此表现得非常豪爽。他们可以接待访客，可以买报纸，各种各样的东西。丘吉尔甚至能够兑现支票。但安保措施非常严密，这让丘吉尔感到沮丧，因为他渴望逃跑。
and everybody else on a train uh lock him up can't get off and they arrive in pretoria and uh there there is a teacher training college that's been built three years earlier called the stutz model school and there they are there they're in prison yeah and churchill says that when they arrived that it was like a new boy at a private school he he unbelievably does things like when he's in prison he tries to have a suit made and he has a man come in to cut it. Yeah, tweed suit. He has the local barber come in to cut his hair. You know, it's a sort of cross between a prison, a boarding school,
我想他渴望逃跑，不仅仅是因为他知道这将是一场对报纸有利、对他的职业生涯有利的戏剧性冒险，还因为他发现自己对被禁锢有着绝对的恐惧。这说得通，对吧？因为他是一个把整个大英帝国当作自己冒险舞台的家伙。所以被这样围困起来，既是羞辱，我想也是极度幽闭恐惧的。是的，我想这是真的。我的意思是，他们在11月18日抵达比勒陀利亚。在长达三周的时间里，他在那里踱步，感到烦躁不安。他总是在谈论这件事。我的意思是，他和别的军官一直在策划各种计划。
and a hotel, it seems to me. Which fits well on the burs, because... They're very well treated. Churchill's very gallant about this. They can receive visitors, they can buy newspapers, all kinds of things. Churchill's able to cash cheques. But the security is very gallant about this. They can receive visitors, they can buy newspapers, all kinds of things. Yeah. Churchill's able to cash checks. But the security is very tight, which is a frustration to Churchill because he is desperate to escape.
他们能不能设法接管监狱？他们能做些什么？所以，任何了解丘吉尔在二战中对疯狂点子的热情的人都不会感到惊讶，他的计划总是极其复杂、带有一种巴洛克风格。但在那里还有另外两个人——呃，我们提到过的埃尔默·霍尔丹，他是火车上部队的指挥官；还有一个叫亚当·布罗基（Adam Brocky）的人，他是个爱尔兰人，是一名军士长，但在南非生活了大部分时间，并参与了詹森突袭。
And I think he's desperate to escape, not just because he knows that it would be a dramatic adventure that would be good for the newspaper, good for his career, but also because he discovers that he has an absolute horror of being confined. And that makes sense, doesn't it? Because he's a guy who treats the entire British Empire as a stage for his adventures. So to be hemmed in like that is both humiliating and I guess very claustrophobic. Yeah, I think that's true. I mean, they arrive in Pretoria on the 18th of November. And for three weeks, he sort of paces around chafing. And he's always talking about it. I mean, they're always concocting schemes, him and the other officers.
我认为他极度渴望逃跑，不仅仅是因为他知道这将是一场对报纸有利、对他的职业生涯有利的戏剧性冒险，还因为他发现自己极度恐惧被禁锢。这很合逻辑，对吧？因为他是一个把整个大英帝国当作他冒险舞台的人。因此，被那样限制在一起既屈辱，我想又非常幽闭恐惧。是的，我认为是这样的。我的意思是，他们在11月18日抵达比勒陀利亚。接下来的三个星期里，他一直在焦躁不安地踱步。而且他一直在谈论这件事。我的意思是，他和另外的军官们一直在策划各种方案。
Could they somehow take over the prison? What could they do? So it won't surprise anyone who knows about Churchill's enthusiasm for mad wheezes in the Second World War that his schemes are always incredibly complicated um kind of baroque um but there are there are two others there so um elma halden who we mentioned who was um in charge of the troops on the train and then a guy called adam brocky who is irish a sergeant major but had lived in south africa for most of his life and had taken part in the Jameson raid.
他们能不能想办法接管这座监狱？他们能做些什么？因此，任何了解丘吉尔在第二次世界大战中对那些疯狂点子的热衷的人都不会感到意外，他的方案总是极其复杂，带有一种巴洛克风格，但那里还有另外两个人，我们之前提到过的埃尔玛·霍尔登，他负责火车上的军队，还有一个叫亚当·布罗基的爱尔兰人，他是一个军士长，但在南非生活了大部分时间，并参加过詹姆森突袭。
So if that had come out, he would have been in real trouble. So that's why he's with the officers. He pretends to a rank. So he claims to be a lieutenant that he didn't actually have. Otherwise he wouldn't be in the- Right. Because the officers and men were in prison separately. Yeah. So it's quite important for him to get out before yeah his captors realize who exactly he is and they essentially fashion a scheme that is a lot less complicated than churchill's which basically involves just jumping over a fence yeah because there's a toilet block basically yeah that there's a particular they watch the centuries there's a particular moment where the centuries have walked past the toilet block and if they they turn and they often turn and they start they're having a smoke and they're chatting
所以如果这件事传出去，他就会有大麻烦。这就是为什么他和军官们关在一起。他伪造了军衔。他声称自己是一个实际上并没有的少尉。否则他就不会在——没错。因为军官和士兵是分开囚禁的。对。所以对他来说，在——是的，在他被俘者确切认出他是谁之前逃出去非常重要。他们基本上策划了一个比丘吉尔简单得多的计划。基本上就是跳过栅栏。对，因为那里基本上有一个厕所方块。对，有一个特定的——他们看着哨兵。有一个特定的时刻，哨兵会走过厕所方块，如果他们——他们经常转身，然后开始抽烟聊天。
the centuries and just for a few moments they have their backs turned and they can't see what's going on and you could then climb onto the toilet block climb over the fence and drop down the other side and the other side this is in sort of suburban Pretoria. So it's just somebody's villa, the other side, the garden. And it's the night of the 12th of December, isn't it? To what Churchill has sort of been badgering the others and saying, let's do it, let's do it. And Churchill being Churchill, he goes first. So he waits for the centurion to chat.
那些哨兵，就在短短几分钟里，他们背过身去，看不到发生了什么，然后你就可以爬上厕所方块，翻过栅栏，从另一边跳下去。而另一边，这有点像比勒陀利亚的郊区。所以另一边只是某个人的别墅和花园。那是12月12日的夜晚，对吧？丘吉尔一直在怂恿其他人，说，我们干吧，我们干吧。而丘吉尔毕竟是丘吉尔，他打头阵。所以他等着哨兵聊天。
And then he, I mean, his rendition of the story is, of course, very melodramatic. It was now or never. I stood on a ledge, seized the top of the story is, of course, very melodramatic. It was now or never. I stood on a ledge, seized the top of the wall with my hands and drew myself up. Twice I let myself down again in sickly hesitation. And then with a third resolve, I scrambled up and over. And all this kind of thing.
然后他——我的意思是，他对这个故事的讲述当然非常戏剧化。“现在或永不。我站在壁架上，双手抓住墙头，把自己拉了上去。我带着病态的犹豫，两次又把自己放了下去。然后带着第三次决心，我爬了上去，翻了过去。”诸如此类的话。
So he's over. And he looks back and he sees the sentries and they're still smoking and they haven't noticed. And then he just, he waits. He waits for the two other bugs time goes by and they just never join him they never come and they basically their moment has never come they don't get the chance and this is a real problem because they've got the provisions and brocky speaks dutch yeah churchill doesn't speak dutch africans so churchill i think has four bars of chocolate in his pocket and that's it and he doesn't speak a word of africans
所以他翻过去了。他回头看，看到哨兵还在抽烟，没有注意到。然后他就等。他等着另外两个人——时间流逝，但他们就是从不跟他汇合，他们从来没有来。基本上他们的时机从未到来，他们没有得到机会。这是一个真正的问题，因为他们有给养，而且布罗基会说荷兰语——是的，丘吉尔不会说荷兰语或南非荷兰语。所以丘吉尔，我想他的口袋里只有四块巧克力，就这样，他一个字南非荷兰语也不会说。
so and he's got his nice brown suit on he's probably quite probably quite hot so what should he do so obviously being churchill he decides well he'll he'll carry on anyway did you see the note he left he left a note on his bed for the prison governor that said um i've decided to escape from your custody so attempts yeah and he's very he's very complimentary isn't he about um he says you know you've looked after me royally and when i get out i'm escaping now i will tell everybody how well you've behaved and he does actually let's meet up and have a good chinwag about it and you yes but you know it's he is now this is highly dangerous for him because he is their most prized prisoner and by escaping he has essentially made himself liable for a death sentence so i mean this is an incredible scene
所以，他穿着那套漂亮的棕色西装，可能相当热。那他该怎么办呢？所以显然，作为丘吉尔，他决定无论如何都要继续前行。你看到他留下的便条了吗？他在床给监狱长留了一张便条，上面写着：“嗯，我决定逃离你们的拘留。所以尝试——”而且他非常、非常客气，不是吗？关于——他说，“你知道的，你们对我照顾得无微不至，当我出去后，我现在要逃跑了，我会告诉所有人你们表现得多么好。”而且他实际上还说：“让我们以后见面，好好聊聊这件事。”没错，但是你知道的，他现在——这对他是极其危险的，因为他是他们最珍贵的囚犯，通过逃跑，他基本上让自己面临死刑的判罚。所以我的意思是，这是一个不可思议的场面。
it's such a hollywood melodrama and so what he has to do he has to what's brought about 250 miles to the um the coast of what's now mozambique mozambique so portuguese east africa so he has to cross about 200 miles of the transvaal without a map without the local any of the local languages no provisions no compass absolutely nothing but he assumes i'm Churchill, I will do it. And so he heads off. It's unbelievable. So he walks through the garden, this filler, with his hands in his pockets whistling, walks down the street, and there are people who pass him.
这太像好莱坞情节剧了。所以他必须做的是——他必须被带到大约250英里外的——现在属于莫桑比克的海岸。莫桑比克，也就是葡属东海岸。所以他必须在没有地图、没有当地的任何当地语言、没有给养、没有指南针、绝对一无所有的情况下，穿过大约200英里的德兰士瓦。但他假设，我是丘吉尔，我能做到。于是他出发了。这太不可思议了。于是他双手插在口袋里，吹着口哨，穿过这个花园、这个别墅，走下街道，有人从他身边经过。
But he's in his sort of civilian brown suit, so nobody really takes a second glance. And he just keeps going. And he's obviously, his mind is racing the whole time. Yeah, it's nearly 300 miles to the coast um and he thinks well the railway that's what i'll head for um this so he he heads for the railway he sees the station after about two hours and he hides in a ditch sort of just beyond the station i mean this is now you know, this is real kind of Ryder Haggard, John Buchan sort of behavior. He waits and waits and waits.
但他穿着那身平民的棕色西装，所以没有人真正多看他一眼。他只是继续往前走。显然，他脑子里一直在飞速运转。是的，离海岸将近300英里，他想，好吧，铁路，那将是我前进的方向。嗯，所以他朝着铁路走去。大约两个小时后，他看到了车站，并藏在车站外不远的一条沟里。我的意思是，这现在——你知道的，这真的是那种赖德·哈格德（Ryder Haggard）、约翰·巴肯（John Buchan）式的行为。他等啊，等啊，等啊。
Night has fallen. He waits. The train goes by. It begins to gather speed. And at that moment, he leaps for the train. He grabs something. He's sort of dragged along for a moment. Then he manages to haul himself up.
夜幕降临了。他等着。火车开过。它开始加速。就在那一刻，他向火车扑去。他抓住了一个东西。他被拖着走了一会儿。然后他设法把自己拉了上去。
And incredibly, he's managed to haul himself up. And incredibly, he's managed to haul himself onto this, the fifth truck along, I think from the engine, the goods train. And he climbs on, I mean, it's real,
难以置信的是，他设法把自己拉了上去。难以置信的是，他设法爬上了这个——我想是货运火车的从车头数过来的第五节车厢。他爬了上去，我的意思是，这真的很像，
you know, Harrison Ford. It's really amazing. And he hides among the coal sacks and he falls, he falls asleep. And then he wakes, um, it's still night,
你知道的，哈里森·福特。这真的很神奇。他藏在煤袋里，然后睡着了。然后他醒来，嗯，天还是黑的，
but he realizes he's got to really get off the train before daybreak so i mean again he um he leaps off the train while it's moving and sort of he doesn't injure himself particularly for once it's still dark i was in the middle of a wide valley surrounded by low hills and carpeted with high grass drenched in dew he finds a pool and he has a drink dawn breaks he looks for the um the sun he's in the absolute middle of nowhere he knows nobody has no provisions his my sole companion he says was a gigantic vulture yes who manifested an extravagant interest in my condition and hideous and ominous gurglings from time to time but so meanwhile back in the prison he has done the kind of the classic
但他意识到他必须在天亮前真正下车。所以我的意思是，他又——他在火车行驶时跳下了车，而且不知怎么地并没有受什么大伤。天还是黑的。“我身处一个被低矮山丘环绕、铺满挂满露水的高草的宽阔山谷中间。”他找到了一个水潭，喝了口水。天亮了。他寻找——太阳。他完全身处荒郊野岭，谁也不认识，没有任何给养。“我唯一的同伴，”他说，“是一只巨大的秃鹫，是的，它对我的状况表现出了极大的兴趣，并不时发出可怕而不祥的咕噜声。”但与此同时，在监狱里，他做出了那种经典的——
you know he's he's put pillows um into his bed to make it look as though he's still there and so an orderly comes in leaves his mug of tea goes back out again and he'd probably been all right maybe for a day except that he'd forgotten that he'd ordered the barber to come in he'd forgotten to cancel it so the barber comes in prods the pillow realizes what's happened the alarm goes off and essentially the whole of transvol now starts to devote itself to the manhunt for churchill and they put out um things saying that he's he's escaped disguised as a woman they offer him yes very like Mr Toad and they make him sound like Mr Toad in the um the descriptions that they offer of him I suppose he does look a bit like Mr Toad he does yeah
你知道的，他把枕头塞进床里，让它看起来好像他还在那里。所以一个勤务兵进来，放下他的茶杯，然后又出去了。如果不是因为他忘了自己曾命令理发师进来，他可能本来可以安然无事好几天，他忘了取消。所以理发师进来，戳了戳枕头，意识到发生了什么，警报拉响了。基本上，整个德兰士瓦现在都开始投入到对丘吉尔的搜捕中。他们发布了——说他是扮成女人逃跑的。他们提供——是的，非常像蟾蜍先生（Mr Toad）。他们在对他的描述中把他写得像蟾蜍先生。我想他看起来确实有点像蟾蜍先生。他确实是，是的。
so it's it's it's all looking very bad meanwhile Churchill is kind of weaving his way slowly eastwards but I mean no I mean it's a long long way and um he he's hoping to catch another train but as the night comes but he you know he waits and waits and waits and no trains come because they've you know they've worked this out so they've cancelled all the trains so what's he going to do now well he sees this eventually after a lot of trudging and um i mean he says actually tom you were talking in an earlier episode about Churchill and his faith. He says this is the one time in his life when he prays, when he's just desperate for something to turn up. And Churchill being Churchill.
所以这一切看起来都很糟糕。与此同时，丘吉尔正慢慢地向东迂回前进。但我的意思是，不，我的意思是，这是一段非常非常长的路。嗯，他希望赶上一辆火车，但随着夜幕降临，他——你知道的，他等啊等啊等，没有火车开来，因为他们——你知道的，他们已经想到了这一点，所以他们取消了所有的火车。那他现在该怎么办呢？好吧，在经历了一番长途跋涉之后，他最终看到了这个。嗯——我的意思是，汤姆，你在之前的某一集里谈到过丘吉尔和他的信仰。他说，这是他一生中唯一一次祈祷，当时他极度渴望能有什么转机。而丘吉尔不愧是丘吉尔。
It does, yeah. Because he sees what seems to be the opening of a mine. And he goes down and he just thinks, I have no choice but to try and brazen this out so he goes and knocks on the the one of the doors of the one of the houses by the mine by the mine opening and the bloke a voice says there is da and churchill says in english he says i'm a burger i've had an accident i was going to join my commando at kamati port i've fallen off the train we were skylarking i've been unconscious for hours. I think I may have dislocated my shoulder. And the man, who Churchill can't really make out, says, come in. So Churchill goes in. And the man is such a Hollywood scene. The man puts a gun down
转机真的出现了，是的。因为他看到了似乎是一个矿井的入口。他走过去，心想，我别无选择，只能硬着头皮试一试。于是他走过去敲了敲矿井口附近其中一栋房子的门。里面传出一个声音说：“查（Da，南非语中的‘是的’）。”丘吉尔用英语说：“我是个布尔人（Burger），我出了事故。我去科马提波特（Komatipoort）加入我的突击队，我从火车上摔下来了，我们在嬉闹，我昏迷了好几个小时。我想我的肩膀可能脱臼了。”那个丘吉尔看不清长相的人说：“进来吧。”于是丘吉尔走了进去。那个人——这真是个好莱坞式的场面。那个人把一把枪放在桌子上，说：“我想我需要更多地了解一下你这次的铁路事故。”然后丘吉尔说：“我想我最好告诉你真相。”那个人说：“我想你是该这样。”丘吉尔说：“我是温斯顿·丘吉尔，《晨报》的战地记者。我昨晚从比勒陀利亚逃出来。我正前往边境。我有很多钱。你会帮我吗？”那个人只是看着他，桌子中间放着一把枪。然后，终极的好莱坞时刻，那个人站起身，伸出手说：“谢天谢地你来了。方圆20英里内只有这栋房子不会把你交出去，但我们全都是英国人，我们会帮你挺过去的。”
on the table and says, I think I'd like to know a little more about this railway accident of yours. And then Churchill says, I think I'd better tell you the truth. And the man says, I think you had. And Churchill says, I am Winston Churchill, war correspondent of the Morning Post. I've escaped last night from Pretoria. I'm making my way to the frontier. I have plenty of money. Will you help me? And the man just looks at him with a gun between them on the table. And then the ultimate Hollywood moment, the man gets to his feet and holds out his hand and says, thank God you have come here. It's the only house for 20 miles where you would not have been handed over, but we're all British here and we will see you through.
（重复，由于原文分块对应问题，此处跳过相同内容的重复编号70，保持与原文索引一一对应）
So by just an incredible stroke of fortune, Churchill has found this man called Mr. John Howard, who's the manager of the Transvaal Collieries, who's been living in the Transvaal for years, but is British and obviously sympathises with the British. And Howard talks to all his men, and they're all pro-British as well. But there's a servant,
所以凭借着不可思议的好运气，丘吉尔遇到了这个人，名叫约翰·霍华德先生（Mr. John Howard），他是德兰士瓦煤矿的经理，在德兰士瓦住了多年，但他是英国人，显然对英国人抱有同情心。霍华德和他的所有手下谈过，他们也都亲英。但有一个仆人，
isn't there, who Howard doesn't trust. And so they decide he can't hide in the house. So there's nothing for it but to hide him down the mine shaft. And so they take him down this mine shaft along the, and there's a kind of side room and they just leave him there in, in the absolute dark on the assumption that there are candles that he can use.
不是吗？霍华德并不信任他。所以他们决定他不能藏在房子里。因此别无选择，只能把他藏在矿井底下。于是他们把他带下这个矿井，沿着——有一个类似侧室的地方，他们就把他留在那里的绝对黑暗中，假设那里有他可以使用的蜡烛。
One of the miners is from Oldham. Did you see this? So from the very constituency that Churchill, Mr. Dewsnap, who Churchill says locked my hand in a grip of crushing vigour. They'll all vote for you next time. So Churchill is down there in the mine.
其中一个矿工来自奥尔德姆。你看到了吗？也就是丘吉尔的选区，杜斯纳普先生（Mr. Dewsnap）。丘吉尔说，他“用一种具有压倒性力量的握力紧紧握住我的手。下次他们都会投你的票。”所以丘吉尔就在矿井底下了。
And he's down there, but they've left him with candles and so they seem that he'll be able to light them. But he gropes around, he can't find them. And in due course, so he spends, what, a day, a night? No, it's three days. Three days, Tom. But he loses all track of time. And eventually they come down and say, you know, well, why don a day, a night? No, it's three days. Three days, Tom. But he loses all track of time.
他就在下面，但他们给他留了蜡烛，所以他们觉得他能够点燃它们。但他摸索着周围，却找不到它们。随着时间的推移，他待了——什么，一天，一个晚上？不，是三天。三天，汤姆。但他失去了对时间的全部感知。最终他们下来问，你知道的——一天，一个晚上？不，是三天。三天，汤姆。但他失去了对时间的全部感知。最终他们下来问，好吧，你为什么不点蜡烛？他说，好吧，根本没有蜡烛。他们说，哦，老鼠把它们吃掉了。他环顾四周，感觉到老鼠在他身上到处爬、坐在他身上、啃咬他，而且它们全都是白化老鼠。非常非常阴森，就像《夺宝奇兵》（Indiana Jones）。但最终，矿井经理想出了一个计划，不是吗？他说附近有一个他们信任的荷兰人，
Eventually, they come down and say, well, why didn't you light a candle? He said, well, there aren't any candles. They said, oh, the rats have eaten them. And he looks around, and he's felt the rats crawling all over him, sitting on him, nibbling at him, and they're all albino. So very, very sinister, Indiana Jones. But eventually, the mine manager comes up with a plan, doesn't he? He says there's a Dutchman nearby who they trust,
正要运送一车羊毛去莫桑比克，运往海岸上现在的马普托。他已经同意，基本上丘吉尔可以藏在火车上的这批货物里。事实也确实如此。所以丘吉尔，当然，他把时间花在阅读上。他带了罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森（Robert Louis Stevenson）的小说。所以他读了《拐拿令》（Kidnapped）。
who's sending a load of wool to Mozambique, to what's now Maputo on the coast. And he's agreed that basically Churchill can hide inside the kind of consignment of water on the train. And that's exactly what happens. So Churchill, of course, he spends the time reading. He's got Robert Louis Stevenson's cutouts, full things with him. So he reads Kidnapped.
（重复，此处略过冗余翻译对应，保持行数一致）
He says he finds it very thrilling. It awakens sensations with which I was only too familiar. So he went to the escape. He escaped on the 12th. He escaped on the 12th. So he's escaped for seven days. It's a week now. On the morning of the 19th, they load him, basically, onto
他说他觉得非常惊险。“它唤醒了我再熟悉不过的感觉。”所以他去逃亡了。他是12号逃跑的。他是12号逃跑的。所以他已经逃亡七天了。现在是一周了。在19号的早晨，他们把他基本上装上了——
the train. The train is being loaded by the mine, and Churchill, they're going to give him the signal. He sneaks out of the mine. Nobody says anything. Nobody looks at him. He sneaks onto a truck and hides among the wool bales. And then darkness descends and off they go. And all day, all night, they travel eastward, the train, through the Transvaal.
火车。火车正在由煤矿装载，丘吉尔——他们要给他信号。他偷偷溜出矿井。没有人说什么。没有人看他。他偷偷爬上一辆卡车，藏在羊毛包中间。然后夜幕降临，他们出发了。整整一天，整整一夜，他们乘着火车向东穿过德兰士瓦。
They go through stations and he hears people talking and moving around him, but he doesn't dare move or obviously say anything. And then eventually they stop and then they're moving again. And he looks through a chink and he sees Portuguese words written on the signs and sees the uniform of the Portuguese officials. And he knows they've got through to what's now Mozambique. And then he kind of pushes his head out from underneath the truck and sings and shouts and fires his revolver in the air with joy because he's out.
他们穿过车站，他听到人们在他周围说话和走动，但他不敢移动，显然也不敢说什么。然后他们最终停了下来，然后又开动了。他透过一条缝隙向外看，看到招牌上写着葡萄牙语，看到了葡萄牙官员制服。他知道他们已经穿到了现在属于莫桑比克的地区。然后他把头从卡车下面探出来，高兴得唱歌、大喊，并向空中开枪，因为他出来了。
He's free. He's out. He's escaped. And he goes to the British consulate, doesn't he, and gets put on a boat to Durban. And that's then the scene that we end this episode with. But it's such a British moment, Tom, when he goes to the British consulate. He presents himself at the British consulate.
他自由了。他出来了。他逃出来了。他去了英国领事馆，对吧？然后被安排登上了一艘去德班的船。这就是我们这一集结束时的场景。但这是一个非常英国式的时刻，汤姆，当他去英国领事馆的时候。他在英国领事馆自报家门。
And the person there says, the consul can't see you today. Come to his office at nine o'clock tomorrow if you want anything. And Churchill goes, loses his temper and says, you know, don't you know who I am?
那里的人说：“领事今天不能见你。如果你需要什么，明天九点钟来他的办公室。”而丘吉尔大发雷霆，说：“你知道的，你难道不知道我是谁吗？”
And all this tells him the story. And then, of course, everybody's delighted to see him. And as you said, they put him on a boat to Durban. And when he arrives in Durban, by the time he arrives, he discovers that the war has been going even worse while he's been away.
然后所有这些都把这个故事告诉了他。然后，当然，每个人都很高兴见到他。正如你所说，他们把他送上了去德班的船。当他抵达德班时，等他抵达时，他发现他在离开期间，战争的局势变得更糟了。
And they've had what's called the Black Week of the British Army, when the British lost three battles in a row, at Stromberg, at Magus Fontaine, and at Colenso, the worst of all, where Redfus Buller had been defeated. 2,000, well, almost 3,000 men have been killed or wounded or captured. The war is going terribly. But his escape is the great news. You can absolutely see how the tabloid press of the day, as it were, sees on this story, this single act of intrepid heroism. And so when he gets off
他们经历了所谓的英国陆军“黑色星期周”，当时英国军队在斯特龙贝格（Stromberg）、马格方丹（Magersfontein）和科伦索（Colenso）遭遇了三连败。科伦索是最糟糕的一次，雷德弗斯·布勒（Redvers Buller）在那里被击败。2000名——嗯，将近3000名士兵阵亡、受伤或被俘。战争进展得糟透了。但他的逃亡是个大新闻。你绝对可以看出当时的黄色新闻报业是如何抓住这个故事不放，抓住这个孤胆英雄的不屈壮举不放的。所以当他在德班下船时，
at Durban, there are bands and crowds on the quays. There are people rushing to shake his hand. He gives a speech where he says they can't possibly lose in South Africa, and everybody's cheering and crying and waving and all of this thing. People shouting, God bless you. And with that, I suppose you could say, I mean, that crowns Churchill's early life, because this is the moment that he's long dreamed of. He is the hero of the empire, because he has redeemed Britain's honour at a time when the generals on the battlefield
码头上挤满了乐队和人群。人们争先恐后地与他握手。他发表了一场演讲，在演讲中他说他们在南非绝不可能战胜失败，每个人都在欢呼、哭泣、挥手，所有这一切。人们大喊“上帝保佑你”。随之而来的，你可以说，嗯，那为丘吉尔的早年生活画上了圆满的句号，因为这是他梦寐以求的时刻。他是帝国的英雄，因为他在战场上的将军们正忙于失去英国荣誉的时候，挽救了英国的荣誉。
have been busily engaged in losing it. Yeah. And he, I mean, astonishingly, he pulls his favourite trick, doesn't he, of going back. And he actually secures a commission. So he's simultaneously a war correspondent and back in the army. He says the next two months are the happiest of his life.
是的。而且他——我的意思，令人惊讶的是，他再次使出了他最喜欢的把戏，不是吗？——回到了前线。他实际上争取到了一个军职。所以他既是战地记者，又回到了军队。他说接下来的两个月是他一生中最快乐的。
He's riding around, the Boers are finally on the run. And he actually ends up going to Pretoria, doesn't he? He does. He goes back into Pretoria in June 1900 with a South African light horse. And he has the pleasure of, as he would call it, liberating the very prison in which he himself had been held prisoner with his cousin, the Duke of Marlborough.
他四处骑马，布尔人终于在逃窜了。他实际上最终去了比勒陀利亚，不是吗？是的。他于1900年6月随南非轻骑兵部队重返比勒陀利亚。他有幸——正如他所说的那样——解放了那个他曾与他的表弟、马尔堡公爵（Duke of Marlborough）一起被关押的监狱。
They go in. There's the prison. Churchill waves his hat in the air and cheers, and all the prisoners cheer. Yeah. They tear down the Boer flag. They raise the Union Jack. I mean, for somebody who had always thought his life was a romantic melodrama, I mean, these must have been transcendent moments, ecstatic moments.
他们走了进去。监狱就在那里。丘吉尔在空中挥舞着帽子欢呼，所有的囚犯都在欢呼。是的。他们扯下布尔人的旗帜。他们升起英国国旗。我的意思是，对于一个一直认为自己的人生是一部浪漫情节剧的人来说，这些一定是非凡的时刻，狂喜的时刻。
Yeah. Because he's living the daydreams that he had had when he was a boy. He's a kind of, you know, hero of all jingo imperialists. But it has to be said that he is, he behaves very well, doesn't he? To the Boers, He sticks up for them. He salutes them as noble adversaries. And we've been talking about this throughout all these episodes, that although Churchill loves a good war and loves the kind of the pinging of bullets around him,
是的。因为他在实现他还是个男孩时曾做过的白日梦。他某种程度上是——你知道的，所有沙文主义帝国主义者的英雄。但必须说的是，他——他表现得非常好，不是吗？对布尔人，他支持他们。他向他们致敬，称他们为高贵的对手。我们在所有这些剧集里一直在讨论这一点，尽管丘吉尔热爱一场精彩的战争，喜欢周围子弹呼啸的声音，
once the war is over, he likes to settle down, have a beer with the opponents, talk over the match, all that kind of thing. And that's basically his approach, that the birds should be treated as honourable adversaries. And this is where he comes up against his old enemy, General Kitchener, whose approach to the birds is not remotely of that order at all. Well, it's scorched earth. So from 1900, 1901, the war slightly changes.
但一旦战争结束，他喜欢安定下来，和对手喝杯啤酒，讨论一下比赛，诸如此类的事情。这基本上就是他的态度，即布尔人应该被当作光荣的对手来对待。这就是他与他的老敌人基奇纳将军（General Kitchener）发生冲突的地方，基奇纳对布尔人的态度完全不是那样的。好吧，那是焦土政策。所以从1900年、1901年开始，战争发生了微小的变化。
The British begin to prevail on the battlefield. Kitchener, first Lord Roberts, and then Kitchener come in to conduct the war in a much more ruthless way. They end up herding the Boers, Boer civilians, into concentration camps so that they can basically starve out the guerrillas. And it then becomes an attritional, very bloody, sort of dirty campaign. And Churchill doesn't really like it. Your characterization, I completely agree with. So Churchill has this motto, in war, resolution, in defeat, defiance, in victory, magnanimity, in peace, goodwill.
英军开始在战场上占上风。基奇纳——先是罗伯茨勋爵（Lord Roberts），然后是基奇纳——开始以一种更加残酷的方式指挥战争。他们最终把布尔人、布尔平民赶进集中营，这样他们基本上就可以饿死游击队员。它随后变成了一场消耗战、非常血腥、某种肮脏的战役。丘吉尔其实并不喜欢这样。你的评价，我完全同意。所以丘吉尔有这句座右铭：在战争中，坚决；在战败中，不屈；在胜利中，宽宏；在和平中，善意。
And actually, it sounds like empty sort of political boilerplate, but he really believes it. So he's constantly writing in his dispatches for the Morning Post or in Telegram's home, we should treat the Dutch farmers with greater magnanimity. You know, they were sort of honourable opponents who we have defeated and now we should extend the hand of friendship, all this kind of thing. And that does mean that although he's a conservative,
事实上，这听起来像是空洞的政治套话，但他确实深信不疑。所以他经常在为《晨报》写的战地通讯中或在给国内的电文中写道：我们应该以更大的宽宏大量对待荷兰农民。你知道的，他们是值得尊敬的对手，我们已经击败了他们，现在我们应该伸出友谊之手，诸如此类。这意味着，尽管他是一个保守党人，
although he then goes and fights an election back in Oldham, and this time, of course, he wins, and Mr. Dusnap from Oldham, his wife is in the gallery. There was general jubilation. Yes, at one of his public meetings. He mentions Mr. Dusnap's name and people say, his wife here his wife's here and everyone's absolutely delighted so he wins but even in in victory he's still making you know he's still saying we should you know we should treat the boers uh better we should reach a sort of honorable peace with them and so forth in fact in his very
尽管他随后回奥尔德姆参加了选举，这一次，当然，他赢了。奥尔德姆的杜斯纳普先生，他的妻子就在楼上旁听席。全场欢声雷动。是的，在他的一次公开集会上。他提到杜斯纳普先生的名字，人们说，他的妻子在这里，他的妻子在这里，每个人都绝对高兴。所以他赢了。但即使在胜利之中，他仍然在——你知道的，他仍然在说，我们应该——你知道的，我们应该更好地对待布尔人，我们应该与他们达成某种光荣的和平，等等。事实上，在他的第一次演讲中——在他的处女作演讲中，那是1901年2月15日，所以战争仍在继续。在他的处女作演讲中，他说过这样的话：“如果我是战场上战斗的布尔人，如果我是布尔人，我希望我能一直在战场上战斗。”保守党长椅上随之泛起了一阵真正的不满情绪。坐在前排长椅上的殖民大臣约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain）喃喃自语，清晰可闻地喃喃自语道：“这就是白白扔掉席位的方式。”换句话说，丘吉尔并不赞同当时在英国政坛盛行的那种沙文主义情绪。所以即使在那个阶段，丘吉尔也是一个与保守党若即若离的成员。而且事实上他在保守党也没待多久——所以在几年内他就退出了。但当然，但由于布尔战争和苏丹以及诸如此类的事情，无论什么样的政治沉浮影响到他，他都被公众心目中——那些对政治不太感兴趣的人——奉为伟大的帝国英雄，一个来自浪漫情节剧的角色。我想，这就是他成名的方式。嗯，一个非凡的故事。我认为这为我们很好地铺垫了接下来的内容，让我们回过头来审视丘吉尔职业生涯的进一步发展，这当然一直到1940年都闪耀着耀眼的光芒和争议。所以我希望你们喜欢这个故事。我想这实际上是我们制作的关于伟大帝国英雄的第二系列剧集，对吧？所以我们讲了戈登将军（General Gordon）。戈登将军。我想丘吉尔通常不被认为是那种类型的人，因为当然，他在第二次世界大战中的记录
maiden in his maiden speech um which is in the 15th of February 1901, so the war is still going on. In his maiden speech, he says the words, if I were a boar fighting in the field, and if I were a boar, I hope I should be fighting in the field. And there's a real sense of sort of discontent that ripples through the Tory benches. And Joseph Chamberlain, the colonial secretary who's sitting on the front bench, mutters, audibly mutters, that's the way to throw away seats. Because in other words, Churchill is not endorsing the kind of jingoistic mood that has sort of prevailed in British politics. So even at that stage, Churchill is a very semi-detached member of the Tory party. And and actually he doesn't last in
在他的首次演讲中，也就是1901年2月15日，当时战争仍在继续。在他的首次演讲中，他说过这样的话：“如果我是一个在战场上作战的布尔人，如果我是一个布尔人，我希望我也会在战场上作战。”托利党议员席卷起了一种真正的不满情绪。坐在前排的殖民大臣约瑟夫·张伯伦喃喃自语，清晰地咕哝着：“这就是自毁席位的方式。”换句话说，丘吉尔并没有赞同那种在英国政坛占上风的沙文主义情绪。因此，即使在那个阶段，丘吉尔也是托利党中一个相当若即若离的成员。实际上他在
the Tory party very long so he's out within within a few years but of course but because of the Burr war and because of the Sudan and all of that kind of thing whatever kind of political vicissitudes affect him he's enshrined in the public mind people who aren't very interested in politics as the great imperial hero the kind of the character from a romantic melodrama. And that, I guess, is how he made his name. Well, an extraordinary story. And I think sets us up nicely to come back to look at the further developments in Churchill's career, which, of course, is a great blaze of colour
托利党并没有待太久，几年内就退出了。但当然，正因为布尔战争、苏丹以及所有这些事情，无论遭遇怎样的政治变迁，他在公众心目中——甚至那些对政治不太感兴趣的人心中——都被塑造成了伟大的帝国英雄，一个仿佛来自浪漫情节剧的角色。我想，这就是他扬名立万的方式。这真是一个非凡的故事。我认为这也为我们接下来探讨丘吉尔职业生涯的进一步发展做好了铺垫，他的生涯当然充满了耀眼的光彩。
and controversy right the way up to 1940. So I hope you've enjoyed that. I guess really that's the second series of episodes we've done on a great imperial hero, isn't it? So we did General Gordon. General Gordon. I guess Churchill is not conventionally thought of in those terms because, of course, his record in the Second World War
掩盖了一切。但当然，在如此年轻的时候取得那样的成就，他去过的地方之广，打过的仗之多，写过的书之多，撰写过的文章之多，这是一项惊人的壮举。也许甚至连他的父亲都会为他感到骄傲。谁知道呢？他也许会吧。不，伦道夫勋爵（Lord Randolph），他可能不会。但我同意你的看法。我认为这确实令人惊异。
dominates everything else but of course that level of achievement at such a young age the the range of places he'd been to the number of wars he'd fought the number of books he'd written the number of articles he'd composed an astonishing feat um and maybe even his father would have been proud of him. Who knows? He might as well. No, Lord Randolph, he probably wouldn't. But I agree with you. I think it is astonishing.
（重复，此处略过冗余翻译对应，保持行数一致）
And I think it's one of those things, it's a bit like writing about Shakespeare or the Beatles or something, because they're so ubiquitous. You're itching to find some way to devalue them and to be revisionist and to therefore say something iconoclastic. But actually, the truth of it, with Churchill's early life, for those first sort of 30 years or so, is that it really is an unbelievably gripping and enjoyable story with this kind of impish, ridiculously overambitious, often very conceited, but enormously endearing and sort of self-mocking, self-mythologising character at the centre who it's impossible, I would say,
而且我认为这是那种让人感觉有点像写莎士比亚、披头士乐队之类的话题的事情，因为他们太无处不在了。你总抓耳挠腮地想找点什么方式去贬低他们，去进行修正主义，从而说出一些打破常规的话。但事实上，关于丘吉尔早年生活（大约前30年左右）的真相是，它确实是一个令人难以置信的引人入胜、引人愉快的故事，故事的核心是一个淘气、荒谬地雄心勃勃、通常非常自负，但又极具吸引力和某种自我嘲讽、自我神话化的人物，我认为——
now maybe not all listeners will agree and that's fair enough, but I would say it's almost, I find it impossible to dislike. And actually the two imperial heroes, I mean, my God. You'd rather spend an evening with Churchill than Gordon, wouldn't you? Yeah, you'd rather spend, I mean, a lifetime with Churchill than an evening with Gordon, I would say. I think an evening with General Gordon would not be, you know, it's not an evening with Dame Edna or something, is it?
现在也许并非所有听众都会同意，这很公平，但我会说，几乎——我发现很难不喜欢他。事实上，这两位帝国英雄，我的天哪。你宁愿和丘吉尔度过一个晚上，也不愿和戈登一起度过，对吧？是的，你宁愿——我的意思是，和丘吉尔度过一生，也不愿和戈登度过一个晚上，我会这么说。我想和戈登将军度过一个晚上不会是——你知道的，这可不是和埃德娜女爵士（Dame Edna）一起过夜什么的，对吧？
An evening with General Gordon. No. Well, anyway, I hope you enjoyed that. Our first Sally into Churchilliana. Great fun. Thank you very much, Dominic, for suggesting it. You're welcome. I hope you all enjoyed it, And we will be back very soon.
和戈登将军度过一个晚上。不。好吧，无论如何，希望你们喜欢。这是我们对丘吉尔生平的初次涉足。非常有趣。非常感谢多米尼克（Dominic）的提议。不客气。希望大家都喜欢，我们很快就会回来。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com that's restishistorypod.com I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦猛料的固定去处，而在我们的
Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。